as another feature film In Your Horizon
what are you actually working on now
um I work on a film that we shoot I
think in uh October November this year
in mostly in Europe
can you give me any more or are you is
it close to the vest
um but it's a story about Patricia
Highsmith who was the the writer of The
Talented Mr Ripley and the stranger on
the train for Hitchcock and stuff like
that so is it a bio film or uh it's
fictional but yeah this this
biographical elements in there for sure
got it uh I like I'm gonna keep on
digging because they have a title yes
you're not going to share yes I can
share it got it uh it's called
Switzerland it's called Switzerland is
it uh do you have a um if you don't mind
me asking who is uh paying for does it
have a distributor like is it no you're
selling it we're putting a package
together oh I like this